[Música]
había una vez un niño adorado
un niño muy querido sus padres
se dedicaron a él
su familia siempre estaba feliz cuando
él estaba cerca
creció para hacer una persona sencilla
noble
buena y siempre dispuesto a ayudar a los
demás
completamente admirable
a sus 27 años philippe
decidió quitarse la vida
mi hermano
con el que había tomado el té la noche
anterior junto con mi mamá
mi hermano con el que me podía quedar
viendo series hasta las 3 de la mañana
mi hermano que me regalaba chocolates
porque si le brillaban los ojos cada vez
que me miraba
durante el tiempo que me tomo contarles
la historia de philippe
tres personas se quitaron la vida porque
cada 40 segundos una persona se suicida
eso significa que cuando yo acabe de dar
esta charla
15 personas habrán fallecido
hoy vengo a hablarles de un tema que no
es muy común del que no van a escuchar
hablar en la calle
el suicidio se lleva 800 mil vidas al
año
y no sé si ustedes saben que bolivia es
el segundo país en américa latina con
mayor tasa de suicidios
el 95% de estos suicidios era
completamente prevenible y prevenible
el 95% de estos casos eran enfermedades
mentales o trastornos emocionales como
depresión ansiedad bipolaridad
esquizofrenia entre otros
enfermedad es completamente tratables de
las que existen mucha información pero
no existe diálogo
una de cada cuatro personas
sufre de estas enfermedades eso
significa que si no es uno de ustedes
que estás estás sentado aquí mirándome
puede que sea la persona que está
sentada a su lado
el suicidio es un tabú del que mucha
gente teme hablar es por eso que las
personas que sufren de este tipo de
enfermedades
y se callan y no piden ayuda porque la
sociedad ha categorizado a este tipo de
enfermedades y este tipo de personas
como débiles cuando en realidad no lo
son
fue después de que mi hermano decidió
quitarse la vida que pude entender la
importancia de este problema una persona
que estaba sentada a mi lado todos los
días
sufría de depresión y yo no me di cuenta
no esperemos que algo así tenga que
pasar para que tomemos cartas en el
asunto
pero qué podemos hacer nosotros con un
estigma y un tabú que ha estado impuesto
en la sociedad por tanto tiempo
empecemos por nosotros mismos
somos una red de contención social que
debe ayudar a una persona cuando quiere
suicidarse y no solamente a un familiar
oa un amigo somos una red de contención
social humana que debe ayudar a
cualquier persona en cualquier momento
de dolor
si somos humanos la otra persona
nos debería importar es nuestro deber y
es nuestra responsabilidad
sólo nos falta subir la cabeza prestar
atención al otro detenerme y preocuparme
por los demás es así que poco a poco y
si cada persona que me está escuchando
ahora toma esta actitud puede ayudar a
que estas vidas sean muchas menos de 800
mil al año
hay que darnos cuenta cuenta de las
señales que son claras y las señales que
no son tan claras como los cambios
bruscos de humor el aislamiento la
persona a veces también puede estar
hablando de querer quitarse la vida o de
la noche a la mañana ya deja de hablar
con las personas duerme mucho duerme
poco cosas que pueden parecer normales
pero a la vez no lo son entonces prestar
un poco más de atención
una de las maneras que según estudios es
una de las mejores maneras para prevenir
el suicidio es creando un diálogo sano
en torno a las enfermedades mentales y
los trastornos emocionales nosotros
tenemos ahora en nuestras manos una
herramienta para lograr generar esto
les hago una pregunta cuando ustedes
están en sus casas están aburridos
incluso algunos durante clases o en su
tiempo libre es lo que hacen
seguramente la mayoría y yo me incluyo
agarra su celular y empieza a ver las
redes sociales como instagram o facebook
bueno en estas redes sociales está una
gran parte de nuestra solución para
prevenir futuros suicidios cuando
entramos a ver esas redes sociales vemos
hay imágenes que postea a la gente
imágenes de personas felices viendo
bailando posando
una parte de su vida sólo nos muestran
una parte de su historia
pero qué pasa si detrás de esas imágenes
y esas fotografías esas personas sufren
de trastornos depresivos o de
bipolaridad y nosotros no nos damos
cuenta hasta que ocurre una tragedia
es ahí donde entra have the story la
otra mitad de la historia hub the story
es una plataforma en redes sociales que
ya ha llegado a más de 25 mil seguidores
lo que quiere hacer esta plataforma es
crear un diálogo sano en torno a la
salud mental y al suicidio lo que quiere
hacer es que la gente gente común como
todos nosotros contemos nuestras
historias personales sin ningún filtro
sin ninguna máscara
después de lo que sucedió con mi hermano
no quería quedarme con los brazos
cruzados
entonces me uní a heart a story como
embajadora aquí en bolivia al abrirme
sobre este tema que no es común mucha
gente y no solamente amigos y familiares
se acercaron a mí para hablar sobre sus
problemas y quisieron publicar historias
ella es alejandra es una de mis mejores
amigas de la universidad después de lo
que sucedió con mi hermano ella se animó
a contar su historia a través de la
plataforma habló sobre sobre su
depresión y algunos pensamientos
suicidas que ella tuvo
ella me dijo que contar su historia le
fue completamente liberador
otro caso boliviano es el de adriana
ella también contó sobre su depresión y
como la sobre llevó día tras día
por otro lado habló que se ve
completamente normal en la fotografía
nos cuenta a través de su historia que
cuando era niño sufrió de un accidente
que le deshizo ambas piernas y en base a
eso él creó otra plataforma para
personas que sufren este tipo de
accidentes para que puedan expresarse y
compartir sus historias sin ser juzgados
yo conté mi historia en la plataforma
hace alrededor de un año
conté sobre como el suicidio de mi
hermano me ayudó a abrir los ojos hacia
un problema de la sociedad
fue increíble cómo recibir distintas
respuestas de personas que yo no conozco
pero querían ayudarme en este momento y
sin juzgarme solamente con él con las
ganas de entenderme y ayudarme a seguir
adelante
cap de story celebra los talentos
ocultos humanos las creaciones las
personalidades incluso las enfermedades
cuando estoy es una plataforma para
todos no solamente para las personas que
sufren de estas enfermedades si alguna
persona quiere contar una historia
personal es completamente bienvenido lo
que queremos conectar the story es que
cuenten sus historias personales y logra
logremos crear un lazo humano y real ya
no las máscaras que ponemos en las
imágenes de las redes sociales porque
ahí no nos damos cuenta lo que pasa con
la otra persona entonces eso es lo que
queremos en hard story y es así como
nosotros
y como jóvenes que somos podemos cambiar
como vemos la salud mental a través de
las redes sociales a lo que estamos
usando todos los días
hoy yo no puedo ir en el tiempo y
detener a mi hermano hoy yo no puedo ir
y abrazarlo más fuerte la última vez que
lo vi
lo único que puedo hacer es planear
hacia adelante porque yo sigo aquí y yo
sigo viva entonces me pongo a pensar en
las cosas que sí puedo controlar
puedo amar puedo sentir puedo ver puedo
reír puedo respirar puedo llorar puedo
vivir
puedo transformar una tragedia en algo
para ayudar y salvar vidas todos tenemos
esa capacidad no solamente yo por lo que
me ha sucedido sino cada uno de los que
está sentado aquí y cada uno de los que
me están escuchando tiene la capacidad
de salvar vidas y de darse cuenta si el
otro necesita ayuda lo único que nos
falta es mirar al otro y decirle tu vida
me importa y no estás solo gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]